[Musique]
alors y en a un autre qui est là c'est
frédéric frédéric dont je voulais dire
des photographes à paris et vous aimiez
bien l'émission savez bien le concept
des tp mp ont déjà le titre départ
touche pas à mon pote touche pas à mon
poste c'est pas mal c'est vrai est
ouvert c'est tolérant surtout dans l'est
justement d'ailleurs je savais que
j'avais appelé le président de sos
racisme dominique sopo à l'époque pour
lui demander ça le dérangeait ima il
m'avait gentiment dit non pas du tout
vas-y tu peux nantes pour d'ivoire c'est
vraiment un bon titre
en plus le concept de départ un forum un
peu critique sur la télé c'est plutôt
pas mal
et puis vous vous êtes sympathique au
départ vous ressembler à mon tonton
georges dans les baptêmes et les barbus
va c'est le type rigolard qui raconte
des blagues et franchement moi j'adore
le voir une fois tous les cinq ans c'est
après je me croise supermarché toutes
les semaines que là c'est un peu plus
difficile
c'est à dire que moi je vous aimais bien
jusqu'à ce que vous tombiez malade que
vous ayez cette maladie un peu chronique
est difficile le syndrome patrick
sébastien walesa voilà un nom mais c'est
dire qu'avant de donner vous êtes
patrick sébastien risée et et je trouve
que ça ça empêcher que au départ moyen
des gens que j'adore valérie j'adore
c'est quelqu'un qui fait des livres
qu'il ya une vraie carrière télé suisse
est atteint c'est une tata aussi c'est
non mais c'est pas ça c'est que le tract
altana jeunes savent qu'ils ont un vrai
parcours qui ont tourné choses à dire
même benjamin il a fait des livres
intéressants sur le cinéma
on essaie pas que les mecs de télé donc
au départ c'était un vrai forum critique
et ça manque un peu la critique libre ce
que je vais rajouter aussi c'est qu'on
nous a dit venez critiqué l'émission
mais dites ce que vous voulez bien sûr
que c'est bien qu'ils aient une
autocritique et si vous restez entre
vous et vous dites vous vous êtes
formidables vous êtes génial ça va pas
marcher
bien sûr j'aimerais que pour ça qu'on
vous a fait des trucs à l'art dix ans -
c'est la mode le bilan le match axa bon
départ j'étais fan de cette émission
maintenant je regarde quotidien pourquoi
parce qu'il ya plus de fonds et que moi
j'ai pas envie d'avoir des nouilles dans
le slip j'ai pas envie de kankan match
est débridée quand matthieu delormeau
est bizuté j'ai l'impression que c'est
moi qui suce visite et ça me fait
toujours un peu
mais quelque part alors à grimaud var
dernière chose eux
j'aime il ya des gens par exemple que
tout le monde critique comme enora je
trouve moi est-ce que c'est très dur
déjà traits d'une femme est d'être belle
et on n'imagine pas ce que ça va être
dans quand elle sort du plateau et
qu'elle se fait harceler attaquer donc
tout est caricaturé vous êtes vous
n'êtes plus des personnes que vous êtes
ici même s'il est vrai vous êtes des
personnages vous donnez des personnages
automatiquement caricaturaux alors tirez
vous et moi j'ai envie de dire j'ai pas
envie d'être misogyne attaquer les
femmes déjà parce qu'elles sont plutôt
bien et très varié va attaquer les
femmes et on peut plus attaqué des gens
qui à un moment donné sont bloqués par
leur personnage il y en a certains alors
qu'ils avaient vous donnez lui répondre
dans un instant d'accord on va se
retrouver dans un instant dans touche
pas à mon poste avec les trois
détracteurs ensuite les chéris bien
entendu on aura eia frédéric qui disait
il ya un instant qu'ils avaient qui
voilà qui il est mais qui n'aimait pas
les missions qui m'effraie l'émission
thierry vous voulez lui réponde sur
certains points oui d'abord on met pas
des nouilles dans le script de tout le
monde tous les soirs c'est vrai quand
même un événement on en a fait un truc
absolument énorme et c'est arrivé une ou
deux fois il ya de temps en temps déjà
arrivé une fois les nouilles 1 le
curseur entre elles avec les infos
médias et sport en est à dire ici le
curseur entre les infos médias les
débats les critiques qu'on peut faire
sur les émissions et puis des happenings
qui sont un peu plus de la déconne
effectivement ils changent suivant les
émissions alors peut-être qu'avec le
temps ça a été un peu plus évolué vers
le divertissement mais on apprend
toujours des choses on arrive toujours à
dire ce qu'on veut sur les émissions
critiques et même les émissions ne s'est
pas un peu dépassé par votre propre
personnage adulé par la vision de
répondre on vous êtes en vase clos et il
ya un moment donné les gens restent clos
parce que moi j'ai un nom dans la
journée ce qui prend le plus la vie des
téléspectateurs non mais pas journée
dans l'âge il ya une blague qui circule
en ce moment sur les élections et vous
qui dit qu on voulait que les français
votre correctement alors qu'il regarde
hanouna la télé qui est en crise
ça c'est une énorme connerie et variées
[Musique]
absolument finir si eric zemmour qui a
sorti ça si vous a partagé les joies du
ris débourser en moyenne
je dis simplement que vous faites partie
de la mémoire collective vous vous êtes
dans la vie de s'attacher à sant est
prise avait une responsabilité énorme
mais on imagine t on une responsabilité
énorme c'est de divertir les gens je
voulais de 19h à 21h il ya assez de
problèmes comme ça sur dans la société
aujourd'hui on vit dans un monde
crédible
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes bien c'est à dire ah non mais
tout à l'heure vous avez dit que vous
regardiez quotidien c'est tabou j'ai
rien contre quotidien que c'est tabou
mais continuons c'est à vous pour moi
aussi il met lara sera je vous dis la
vérité c'est pas des émissions je
regarde parce qu'il met la thrive m
l'angoissent moi je pense que les
français le soir pourquoi tpm pays
numéro un c'est parce que les gens ont
envie de se vider la tête d'apprendre
des choses et de se divertir
aujourd'hui on n'a qu'une fonction c'est
de divertir les gens moi le plus beau
cadeau qu'on puisse me faire c'est quand
quelqu'un dans la rue me dis merci cyril
et merci à toute l'équipe parce que
quand on rentre le soir avec la famille
la démission et on s'amusait pas
désignés par leur énergie vous étiez pas
sympathiques je n'ai simplement
réellement donné vous êtes tellement
exposé c'est compliqué frédéric de voir
ce que vous provoquez mais accepté
l'année trouve que si vous laissez même
pattern au même jean-michel moi je les
adore mais à un moment donné il est le
vieux boat service sa doit être pénible
pour lui alors partir juste un truc et
d'eric j'ai un truc vrai dans votre
phrase je veux dire on n'est pas des
professionnels pas dire d'être justes le
vieux beau de service je pense que déjà
je pense pas être juste je suis vieux
oui je suis bon c'est pas ben oui oui
oui oui
si les mains d'éric l'a dit oui à la vie
et moi franchement je me suis jamais
autant marrer dans ma vie
professionnelle que maintenant voilà je
rentre chez moi je suivais le comme j'ai
jamais été heureux
ouais j'ai fait des trucs sérieux et
j'ai fait les choses différentes mais
maintenant je m'amuse et me donne
légèreté général armée a pas vous jure
que c'est vrai nom mais je vous le dis
et c'est bien que vous soyez venu c'est
vrai que ici tout est dit tout le monde
est hyper heureux de faire l'émission et
je pense que c'est surtout m'estime des
zones sais pas si le type qui sépare de
lui dire je vous dit que ça le dérange
dans série n'aurait pas dépassé par
notre personnage parce que moi après je
retrouve mes enfants ma famille mais
tous n'ont jamais rien lâché c'est ce
que vous contrôlez ce que vous avez dit
qu'on devient des personnages de fiction
alain malgré nos oreilles parce que
l'émission est très forte elle a une
grosse visibilité et les gens vont
penser que effectivement jean michel et
le vieux bolivie dit notre service et
qu'il n'est que ça
allez de l'écran mais quand l'émission
s'arrête il est cola mais juste pour
revenir au quotidien le quotidien
finalement nous ici on donne pas de
leçon on est vraiment je pense beaucoup
plus dans l'autodérision on dit pas ce
qui est bien et ce qu'est le mal on dit
parce qu'il chipe qu'est-ce qui est pas
chic on dépasse qui est intelligent et
fier qu'on ait je trouve que c'est la
grande force de l'émission ce
contrairement à l'émission le quotidien
par exemple qui vous apprend toute la
journée
comment il fait intelligent fédérer chic
et fort j'avais quand j'arrêterai
l'émission vous jure que c'est vrai
quand on me de ça marche pourquoi ont
été nommés n'ont même pas du tout mais
une fois qu on s'amusera plus une fois
que les gens ici s'amuseront plus et une
fois qu'on me dira vous êtes devenus des
donneurs de leçons non mais ce qui me
rendait compte à quel point vous êtes
important dans ce sens notre pays'' la
réal et je vous jure on va vous savez
quoi frédéric ben vous avez raison on ne
s'en rend pas compte parce qu'on y voit
je vous jure que c'est vrai ça sert on
ne se rend pas compte qu'on est ici pour
s'amuser nous vraiment on se rend pas
compte et on a juste envie que les gens
s'amusent avec nous tous les soirs
gilles après jour et entonne le
troisième détracteurs qu'on n'a pas
entendu encore mais frédéric j'avais est
excellent en tout cas c'est moi j'ai pas
envie de vous casser juifs mais prévient
que nous avons simplement s'arrêter et
que je suis un spectateur lambda je vous
dis ce que je pense mais moi je veux pas
que ça vous savez que mes amis me disent
mais pourquoi tu es venu chez hanouna ce
soir c'est la honte de ma chambre
alors que j'ai pas que des amis alors je
vais vous dire c'est pas du tout là où
il ya des gens vraiment de tout bord qui
s'égarent ça oui mais vous le dit à des
gens qui m'ont dit que mon stigmatiser
ce soir en disant tu vas pas aller chez
hanouna c'est le bas de gamme à chaque
soir alors que non au départ
l'émission lé pa bas de gamme qui avait
germé ravel et si on n a jamais été ma
de gamme et il ya des gens justement
c'est une émission familiale et c'est
une émission populaire
c'est pour ça que tous les soirs tpp est
le talk show le plus regardé
alors qu'elle était au cachot plus
élitistes comme c'est à vous quotidiens
qui sont moins vu mais voilà qui font
voilà des choses qui nous corresponde
mois gilles là où je suis en complet
désaccord avec vous avec tout mon
respect c'est quand vous dites que nous
ne sommes plus des personnes nous sommes
des personnages non non non non non non
non non mais si on est maintenant et où
vous nous sommes non non nous sommes des
personnes totalement humaine
profondément humaine avec nos qualités
nos faiblesses 10 mais on est jeune et
nous mêmes totalement coupé les riches
quoi qu'elle a compris
mais qui dit je vous adore jouer non non
je ne connais pas les mêmes et pour
pécho jolie voix pâteuse